Die 23. Olympischen Winterspiele in Pyeongchang sind
beendet.
Mit einer farbenfrohen Abschlussfeier verabschiedet
Südkorea die Athleten aus aller Welt.
IOC-Präsident Thomas Bach lobt die Spiele
als "erfolgreich in jeder Hinsicht".
Sie haben auch zu einer Annäherung zwischen
Nord- und Südkorea geführt.
Zum Abschluss laufen Athleten der beiden verfeindeten
Bruderstaaten gemeinsam hinter ihren eigenen Flaggen ein.
Auf der Ehrentribüne sitzt neben Südkoreas
Staatspräsident Moon Jae In und US-Präsidententochter
Ivanka Trump auch ein ranghoher General aus
Nordkorea.
Die Nordkoreaner sollen sich am Rande der
Spiele offen für Gesprächen mit den USA gezeigt haben.
Washington hatte jedoch zuvor die Sanktionen
gegen Pjöngjang weiter verschärft.
Mit 14 Mal Gold, 10 Mal Silber und 7 Mal Bronze
hat die deutsche Mannschaft ihr bestes Ergebnis
bei Olympischen Winterspielen erzielt.